ah the music went away hey what's up
guys hello happy today Thursday yeah
days Thursday I'm losing track of time
how are you doing gently I'm doing ok
all right cool I brought you in to play
some PlayStation classic well we're
starting off with a game I well I
thought we were on not anymore
technically you could have this one too
um well yeah we're gonna get us out live
live everyday 11 a.m. PDT Monday to
Friday I always say every day every day
seems easier than Monday to Friday
anyways we get every weekday so there's
20 games yep of which some are as people
know now NTSC and some are pal I can
tell you those later what are your
favorites out of these 20 I'll tell you
mine a geez 20
yeah it's a metal gear yep mm-hmm
there's some caveats with this one that
maybe prevents it from being the version
I would play retro Resident Evil
director's cut okay solid I like that
they use the Director's Cut version
because it's the version that has a
really bad music and that's hilarious
noticeable there's no way to like play
that regular version at Mart because
every every digital version of this is
the director's guy persona is not a game
that holds up but I think it's cool they
put it on got to get like a Japanese
import game con in there yeah you know
personas popular nowadays so that kind
of makes sense puzzle fighter I like a
lot Tekken 3 is always cool I don't
really play like twisted metal or
anything I enjoyed it as a kid my
fantasy 7 is ok I've never beaten it
hey who are you check that's a man like
six slap them in and that's about it
that's fair I would go Metal Gear Solid
okay it'd be fine that I don't know I
don't know if it holds up still but
twisted metal like I said a plate of
lunch as a kid I owned that game I hear
a lot of clean that they should've put
two because it's the better one well
okay yeah I missed a legit for me right
that's why classic right puzzle fighter
for sure Tekken 3 yeah I've got a gotta
have me some eddy gordo ff7 I think I
said that you know yeah that's kind of
where it stops for me yeah there's some
other stuff that's fine but those are
those would be the ones I'd care about I
actually never owned the PlayStation as
kids I don't have the like that's fair
direct assault by idea I went over to
friends houses that's fair I got my
video game I had my PlayStation and I
used to burn games nice yep hell yeah
old the young Eric no no money Eric had
to had to make some of his own games now
I would either you'd have liked those
friends it's like this friends got the
Xbox this friends got the dream that's
awesome like so yeah we yeah I had a
friend had a Dreamcast you'd figured
that out and you'd be like all right -
we can all go hang with this friends
that definitely worked out for me I had
a friend with Dreamcast we switched to
the
we totally bought the Japanese version
of MBC two Rovers Capcom - played the
crap out of that - like the disc I don't
know something bad happened to the disc
or something that we had to buy another
one that's how much we played it dang
that unlike Power Stone Crazy Taxi was
good - oh this kind of feels weird feels
a little smaller than I'm used to
because I know but I'm using ps4
controller like on a date like on a more
regular basis so controllers pretty good
it's the same size what's up -
supersonic game original controller I
think it's like it's tad bit lighter and
what I remember but it's it feels good
it feels pretty late but I mean like the
buttons don't feel like worn down and
all like glossy yeah that's like good
it's like a solid good alright first
game well just do a quick best of three
or something and then we'll switch games
I don't know anything
oh it's all about Ken makes it too easy
but Ken's my boy it's like can you chain
and Cleo Cleo like if you break
something and then yeah it's again like
that then yeah you get more for chaining
rockin go henshin super puzzle find her
really hey man hey man start off do I
play this in the arcade I got what oh
yeah this is just that he can build more
bigger pistols never been good at maybe
we only play one round at this item and
we'll see
[Music]
lisa has darker drops are pretty good
they have not been very easy not getting
any okay so this doesn't work quite like
that like come on higher plated on eyes
that you got to get four in a row
oh yeah you can do whatever you can
scratch whatever it's trying to change
I'm gonna die because of it probably
what do you guys want to employ how
about that well I thought well loosely
follow that
oh no no no no John Luke no I'm probably
good I'm probably good okay I'm okay
okay I'm trying to I'm trying to chain
here sometimes it takes a little longer
to to think about these remix yeah I've
never been good enough to like think
ahead uh twisted metal they should have
added bus and moved to Oh what about bus
to groove let me go minute I like that
game or I don't know the entire reason
for it but there's a couple of really
obvious processes get on here upset have
remasters and that makes me think like
they want the remasters to be the Spyros
[Music]
I'm thinking of something known for some
reason I'm thinking of a jam
can't help you because I can't read your
mind
oh yeah this will be good why are you
giving up don't give up give it up sit
Soul Reaver silent hill
all right what do you want to play now
we should switch games sure yeah do you
want to try twisting metal sure I that's
another one just put out there I don't
know if I play but we'll see how that
goes
I definitely don't know how to play so
you just drive around and your shoots
destroy other cars and stuff
how sweet tooth has fallen once a staple
rapper the rapper rapper yeah but did
Beckett that's what I'm saying I got a
remaster well remaster they just like
put it on ps4 alright single track fire
oh you want to do a two-player duel
No look at look at that grimy clown yeah
I'm a taxi driver
[Music]
now it looks like Vince McMahon or the
WWE I guess you got your business may
have owned that car crazy taxi Dreamcast
Dreamcast I think I'm pretty sure
Dreamcast
oh definitely not oh he's a goat damn
there was this many characters I
honestly don't remember this many voice
me too if two words the Dreamcast
classic I feel like that actually I
don't know I think there's more like
lost great games for the Dreamcast like
you can
you can pool like a lot of the best oh
I'm getting rocks fighting games around
the brink ask I honestly don't remember
the buttons not gonna lie alright this
is going well okay okay okay it's all
coming back to me now alright okay I
think wow this game did not hold up well
let me tell you is
the cars that they were like lighting me
up other opponent cars where are you
playing virus oh there's one big dummy
yeah I don't know to be honest right
it's not very good I have got some
machine guns I got a special probably
one of these like hell but oh yeah that
was probably it Oh nope you got me is
that it I'm just okay it's gonna say you
have more than one chance is there oh oh
this is probably like an only one car
thing
he fires asking if anyone to get out of
hockey yeah well it's not officially out
yet to my knowledge that's definitely
something I'm curious about it but what
the hacking community can do with this
thing hello because I guess we plugged
in controllers like into your PC all
right we got we got a one there yeah all
right let's switch game I'm done
oh man it's fine all right
Resident Evil sure this at least will
last for a little bit yet so this is 120
minutes I think people have mixed
feelings about this one as far as how
holds up I know some people are like and
it's not that great anymore I actually
still really like it because I actually
fun fact I did not play Resident Evil 1
until 2000 like 11 mm-hmm and it was
like right around the time when they
were doing when they when they were
putting out the resin evil HD like
remaster on people okay yeah because I
was like man I've actually never played
the original resume though I should play
it and I played it and actually had a
really fun time
this stops between tasks is pretty good
I like it yeah a lot of people kind of
saying what you said earlier that they
they would have wished for twisted metal
too instead of water that's a tough one
because it's like yeah do you go for the
nostalgia of the original or do you like
pick the better up game yeah 25 clams
Minh says top five that I wanted we're
driver Medal of Honor
medieval broken sword wounds here's
another one where you're likable man
they got that remaster it's true if
anything though that remaster is still
not out yet so for me I felt like you
put this out here and be like hey here's
the original now go buy the you want to
go play for the new and let out antidote
says I'd rather have had Street Fighter
II X plus alpha and ex2 plus on PS
classic that's fair
peers classic lacks good game says Alex
there's a few that are I think pretty
good but I think for the scope of what
they could have really gone sure I mean
that's ultimately gonna be a couple of
them what we're searching probably don't
worry about through Alex some of the
games are PL or European paddle battle
arena toshinden cool borders to
destruction derby this is the pal
version Grand Theft Auto murder case
Simpson flash hog world Abe's Oddysee
blandish as you mentioned resident you
book the records guy for Pocket Anna
take it three victims and Tom Clancy's
Rainbow six Bravo Team went to the hide
home where I'm like man I love to that
game on the PC I don't know why I would
ever be like ah yes the PlayStation
version that's where it's at I'm like
that's a weird one to make that's a good
call rival schools instead of totient in
I guess sure
the stream is brilliant Raoh cheers hang
sir
nobody was one game at a time strangely
most of the equipment job on that Barry
did like a little that's Wesker we know
with a very before Wescoe I might have
been buried yeah Barry there's Jill yeah
that's Chris what is so fun fact this
version the director's cut was
advertised as having new Gore in it and
having dis opening cutscene be in color
because the reason it's in black and
whites because they wanted to cut down
off the gore okay and so they were like
hey this version of life we have but
they forgot to change it so on the back
of the box it says like new cutscene
like added Gore in color with version
still doesn't have it great run Jill
Wesker this is great
loving this yeah crazy our boots make a
bit sure I also just talk a little
that's fine I got someone else anytime
we do like a video with multiple people
I'm always the quietest soft-spoken
Wesker run close-up yeah that house Oh
[Music]
PNG house
oh yeah then they do like a intro yeah
Redfield see ya there same color but
that was always like that she'll
Valentine won't they got their blood
type man you're talking about that
imagine if they sold you these costumes
now Halloween oh yeah berry Rebecca
chambers I'm a martial artist man my man
Wesker always cool Resident Evil yeah it
does not play the ps1 discs if you're
curious it's like a little tiny box I
would show it to you but I can't tables
unfortunately pretty much like this big
yeah there may be a little bit bigger
give or take what red Lexus incredible
crisis that games what a mansion what a
mansion could we skip this I don't think
you can actually you can what you want
to skip this these graphics open that
door what was that noise
maybe it's Chris now Jill can you go I'm
going with you
this is our old partner you know yeah
okay let me handle this loving it
stay alert all right you got it captain
yeah these door animations so good what
what is this what is it Jill see if you
can find any other clues I'll be
examining this hope this is not blood
all right wow what a mansion yeah the
Winston st. John says the best looking
game on this is Rainbow six yeah we
couldn't go look at that way I mean my
feeling Metal Gear Solid at least so
what were you saying
um was wrong with Metal Gear that it's
not the version good oh I'm saying it's
not the version I play because one it
doesn't have there's no dual shocks you
know I'm for thumbsticks you don't have
the vibration which at that point was
very much a thing and like games like
Metal Gear like greatly are enhanced by
those thumb sticks and by the vibration
so if you do the psycho mantis fight you
can't do the controller vibration also
he'll never know what saves I have he'll
never know what saves you have because
Metal Gear is the only Castle bait or
the only Konami game there's no like
Castlevania there's no like there's
nothing so like yeah you can't be like a
racer
is that not so much crazy its Ridge
Racer no that's Namco Samko I don't like
he wouldn't he wouldn't have anything to
say and I'm like well that sucks like
wait did you you beat that game right
yeah so I beat do you have to switch to
the second controller for it to beat him
that's how I did it yes you have to I
think there is maybe a way around it but
yeah that's probably the easiest way
yeah yeah it's a Namco yeah I mean I'm
trying to think what he said to me when
I went out with my saves
oh man yeah he didn't say I think he
just said something like Castlevania for
me he definitely said something to me or
maybe he was like oh you haven't played
any other ya got no save like so it's
like you're cuddling you're not getting
the full experience there although
apparently there's a part in the game
where they're like you have to call
Merrill and you have to they're like oh
look at the the codec on the back of the
box and they just the picture so they
apparently put that picture as one of
the images on the back of the
PlayStation classic box which is pretty
good we said smart
yeah so somebody did think that through
and I I appreciate you yeah whoever did
that is nuts that's okay try playing
some Metal Gear Solid the only thing is
like that's got a long kind of like
beginning to right I think yeah it's
just a lot of cutscenes and stuff like I
don't know how interesting that would be
it's compared to this beautiful
animation here
Gustavo not a fan of the PS classic says
it's just good as like a nice shelf
decoration ornament that's kind what
Peter's thing like it's a very well
designed little little thing like a
little little shell it looks really like
someone put a lot of effort into making
that thing like crafting yeah like the
hardware looks nice we get we can we can
try to hop into MGS later sure sure why
not those games will take longer we're
not gonna show off every game here
that's low I'm basically no use to you I
did not play our games no no no I really
I did play seven though now you're just
supposed to like kinda walk on them and
explore check everything and then go
back to Barry and be like I don't know
where should i what should I do
yeah oh hey Barry you should you should
play seven you should play seven in VR
like horrifying it's great I still want
to play an on switch Japanese like the
stream the game like what they do with
the Odyssey except Odyssey worked we're
talking about Assassin's Creed obviously
right yeah yeah yeah that works much
better than well obviously we're trying
to hit a testing server so that we
shouldn't start from the first floor
okay there it is there's one thanks
maybe I'll need it man into think I
probably thought these graphics are good
as [ __ ] back in the day so sure why
checking through the palette or then
have that pre-rendered stuff looks so
good I don't know why that dad they ever
said why they took the palace I think
they want to see there's like a blog
post about it right where they finally
like kind of admitted to it they
admitted to it but they need to read I
need to reason like what was the
reasoning for picking it like why did
you actually not pick the American
version or the NTSC version
okay so we're gonna go I at least want
to get to Jill sandwich actually I
should go pose backhand gonna save
Reddit one that's how I find it
do I have mine
race then I hold that hold it down okay
[Music]
yeah gimme that increment I'm gonna do
some saves yep just in case
evil 3 on here president 3 is the worst
damn I take shots fires
I have no stake in this so I'm not gonna
die respect people's nostalgia for that
game but having gone back and played all
the older resonance recently that one
holds up the least that one's got
problems - worse than musics choose the
best now - just ask him to get
clarification you know they're also very
different games at that point but - is
probably the best of the original
original games so come over Tessie says
can't wait for remake - it should be
good yes I'm very excited we make - it's
early next year - right
oh no cinema be how that's still good
yeah I'm fine
more ink ribbons twisted metal is on
here Sean we played it for a hot second
and then switch games mainly because I
don't remember how to play it well and
second I did I want my match and I
called it a day legit one how you doing
heuristics is the best one in my opinion
I feel like you're trolling so hard
there are people who I mean it it's one
of the best-selling which is crazy to me
he's fine come on fun come on
[Music]
I think the bots will just pick up links
so probably don't bother sitting there
you go
got to reach up into that statue and put
that item
good try move it a little bit back
thrilling gameplay right come on lemon
controls I love them
no I think I got one more you think you
think you're good or you think you got a
nudge I probably got a nudge it a little
bit feel like got it damn
who would ever put the map anyways
there's a lot of questions about the
layout of this mansion so it's a Pepsi
man yeah no Pepsi man my the one who
like chicken run on ps1 actually played
a lot of that game I played on PC but it
was the same game you can't send links
so you can stop trying good dogs
ah quick to the door oh you got caught
up on that chest or whatever vanity you
think you're still fine you check I have
a health item yeah I'm okay Omari says
I'm sick that Wild Arms - is it on ps1
classic that was a RPG I never got to
play heard good things about it though
yeah I've never played either did you
know you could hold square to run I've
been doing that Tory MPs was good yeah
Toy Story 2 it's just mario clone but it
was good anything in this toilet nope my
poop uh yeah so check it out the PS
classic if you guys didn't know that's
John Luke over there I'm Eric what up
gamespot live live every weekday at
11:00 and thanks for liking chicken run
you're welcome are you guys I think so
um Marty are online or maybe we're not
sure if how well that was the bility huh
stability but also like you can't make
like private stuff in that game so it's
sort of just like hoping you can get
people to join which we're not really
sure we're not really sure there how's
the controller boys
is fine controllers good yeah controller
feels it's a for me right now it's just
getting used to the fact that it's
smaller but it is very much like it was
in the past just doesn't like you said
no DualShock no dump sticks and stuff
like that alright can you burn CD ROMs
to on this reboot console no you can't
sorry ooh the shot it's like the shotgun
Diego Sanchez wants to bless the n64
classic hoping for one you know it's
funny I still have a 64 and so does my
fiance so I feel like it's not even that
hard to get a 64 now getting good
contrition might be another good
controllers probably come with games Oh
The Sandman I wonder if like how in how
tense this moment would be though if you
didn't know what was gonna happen sure
you're probably just like why don't the
doors open he almost sounds like the
king of the hill yeah kinda
some more active day oh you even have to
have a little open door animation to
that door got was to destroy their you
jokester yep this one's found are you
here the thing I was wondering about Dan
64 to check myself for controllers
because so far all of these systems yeah
I've only ever supported two controllers
correct which makes sense but then it's
like well in 64 the whole thing was like
Mario Kart play split screen right now
Goldeneye perfect are they're not gonna
get Goldeneye if they do that they're
gonna get perfect dark you're not gonna
write that game I think they could
convince Microsoft to give them like
access to like banjo and perfect dark
they are not gonna get gold Goldeneye
you want to play it anyways it does not
hold up well I played it like a couple
months ago thinking like yeah Goldeneye
you know it's like oh my god this is not
good no no I use butts I agree this is
not good people wanting it just not
quash your expectations now
this is a very resilient zombie
I said you know what for the blood head
shadow
headshot that dead yet got him yep just
keep that little what game you guys on
your next don't know it's a good
question which are the same time we want
yeah you wanna do let's do something
else
I'm not sure let's just showcase the
robust twenty games you've gone through
yeah yep and fun fact so you go the
memory card it is there nice keeps the
original icons which is kind of cool and
they also have like flashpoint saves for
every game so I could just like resume
it if I wanted which is cool yeah
cron says play Tekken alright let's do
that sure Goldeneye source is somewhat
good I've heard so I've heard a lot of
people say like oh like they've there
there's like a community who's like
taking gold and I put it on like PC day
and like modded it would like mouse and
keyboard some more and I've heard a lot
of people are like into that I pass it I
mean the real 6 if you want to play like
Goldeneye like or like a good Goldeneye
job you play you play a time crisis
Crisis crisis is the I I always say the
wrong thing with no but that game was
like like so sick back in the day the
first time we came out yeah because
you're ducking you're stepping on the
pedal they're like pop back out and
shoot and like reload your gun kappa
where i'm in time splitters yes
tekken is pal which is a fifty eight
Hertz version yeah what is here is your
goldeneye successor get that versus oh
we got like no characters oh but I got
eddy gordo you just families kick button
just pop up and you're fine all right
it'll be metal gear don't worry I know
[Music]
okay don't worry wrong is the same to
you just spam the kicks you know
everyone wants mgs Yeah right
that's very alright well we'll get those
look at that background yeah I do sweet
capoeira it's so slow
it is really flown all right we got a
mixing some punches to throw you off
I finally established my beat oh I want
a light gun classic constantly I'll do
Hong nan I would really be a real tough
challenge because the whole reason the
light gun worked was because of the way
CRT is working so you like moderate old
light gun tech doesn't work yeah I want
it done real bad for NES classic I would
play I had area 51 on my playstation 1
Oh
back in the day though I'm not saying
they couldn't do it they would just have
to completely change the tech behind it
and that might cause some group
compatibility issues with the game so
it's possible they would just have to do
a lot of work to make it happen I don't
know for it's worth it's a lot of these
companies to do that because I'm with
you in theory I would love that
I will play one more hold the other
boring I don't know I'm not bad the data
you don't know I love all the games were
played I will say like I know I think
ff7 even holds up that well no like I
tried going back and playing I was like
wow this is yeah he used to have that
one button when you just mash for time
you get for kicks
oh thank you so much Wow Bob Jones like
gun I'm just saying if you wanted to do
like older games okay use like like
those older like guns they would have to
do some work to like make those
compatible it's pop it's definitely
possible it would just take a little bit
of work
I'm cheap oh that was a good move that
was the one where you get popped up and
then you can combo it I did play this
game because I had does it have a
Fighter II X plus alpha no unfortunately
it is not alright next game just redo
Metal Gear I want to talk about Metal
Gear yeah let's do Metal Gear let's get
it out of the way before everyone starts
raging that we haven't played some Metal
Gear I know someone who wanted battle
arena toshinden on the closet that's
cool they got it yeah that's great job
Erik you just twice beat a girl with a
male character hey man I could have
played a female character it's fine
please play Kazuya that's too late it's
too late sorry killer cam oh don't worry
we got mgs loading don't worry what do
you what do you think that stranding
will come out on the PS 5 sorry year
give me a year Oh
[Music]
I'm going between 20 20 or 20 21 spare
okay so 2020 the fun back foot lab with
20 20 is it is a Sony anniversary I
believe it's like I forget how many
years since the place is yeah this is
good David Hayter man yeah I'm thinking
late late 2020 or okay so 2020 would be
the 20th 20 years of Playstation [ __ ]
really yeah I think I think they have
already done 20 years PlayStation
tonight I screw that up yeah all right
hold on hold the whole East Asian side
I've been around there's a there's a
there's like a there's like a specific
is a console thing right here when did
places maybe PlayStation 2 PlayStation 2
like 94 - snow can't be that decision -
20 years there you go PS - 20 years
after the ground oh wait that was Japan
though oh my god that's still actually
yeah mm hmm yeah mm so so 20 years since
the ps2 man that was a really long time
in between do you think that would be a
ps5 launch title though Oh launch title
I don't know about that I still think
like I don't think Last of Us C will
take that long but that would have been
a better launch title probably I think
yeah I'm thinking that if they do like a
fall release for the PlayStation but I
could see it being like the codec I can
see who's trying to do it and then melee
actually we got a delayed u21 like you
know this is the only Metal Gear
I played and be multiple times good i I
stop that - I don't know why I couldn't
get into - cuz like I felt like it made
- it made me have to stealth way more
than I wanted to then I was getting
punished for not doing it right like
dude I'm so conditioned in mgs that I
could do either one I don't know and
then I'm kind of sad I didn't play that
much revengeance I probably should be
vengeance grats a good game revengeance
is really good I'm surprised there
hasn't been a revengeance - to be honest
or something in that vein but me too and
no I'd maybe didn't sell that well cuz I
revengeance it's great it's real dumb
it's got some great music the combats
really good
good I like it okay
I'd love to see these codex again for
smash I'm going to play this for the
first time when I get classic awesome I
mean it'll still be cool but man if you
could have played on PlayStation and
like get through that psycho mantis
fight that was that was [ __ ] right there
man I remember the first time I fought
him I was like we got what was that
noise oh you feel the vision isn't big
enough oh what a bad time for a call to
the ground you'll just have to wait for
the elevator to come down thanks
the button areas wait
you hide in a box
choked some guys out did you get um did
you ever get the bandana and the cloak
oh yeah yeah which one is that the cloak
is if you save if I forget it Merrill
dies and you have Auto Connie and you
get the cloak yeah then you get the band
Dan if you save cloak was the best
because you could just walk around to
these dumb soldiers and they'd be like
huh and then you just get to choke them
out for free
I'm okay I didn't have to hit something
and I forgot I think honestly don't
remember to be honest I think I'm good
this is just so they can get through all
the credits
okay yeah all right
looks like he has a famas
snake snake actually my favorite
character in this game is for a gray fox
gray fox is real good
that guy's a badass I think it made me
well after playing it made me want to
make like all my screen names if I could
like gray fox fox gray fox this gray fox
that yeah there is actually a guy that
usually are a person that usually shows
up in our chat called gray box a fox
yeah and usually shows up that's a great
name the zombie killer really wants to
do Rainbow six all right well I'll try
it it's fine I'll give it a go get rid
of all our swimming gear here no one
will suspect
[Music]
graphics better than wow pogchamp
I'm better than well classic
tactical espionage action metal here so
yeah great box double zero seven zero
zero I wonder if there's that many gray
foxes ahead of him how the hell did you
get a PlayStation classic we have like a
review copy version if you want check
out Peters review yep on gamespot comm
also there's a video review John Luke
actually cut that no no
second three equals best game on PSE I
don't know about that but if that is
yours Julianne that's fair
please not swing cool play sympathy
other name we got a ps2 classic take it
easy I'm grateful if it weren't for your
suit and your shot I would have turned
into a popsicle out there an anti
freezing peptide snake all of the genome
soldiers in this exercise are using it I
see I'm relieved to hear that already
tested huh oh by the way how's the
diversionary operation going yeah two
f-16s just took off from Galena and are
headed your way
the terrorists radar should have already
picked them up
Heidi
fine d Colonel what's a Russian gunship
better boy right there
football is revolvers got their
attention
where's my cat noticed
I'm assuming
I'm gonna look it up before I ask
although it probably would have taken a
deep deep dive or
yeah we have it oh yeah I thought about
it around
Eli guys though it takes so long I
thought about around survived but I was
like survived that came out this year
boy sorry I haven't introduced you to
yet this is Mei Ling
Mei Lin she was assigned to us as our
visual and HR specialist she designs
Tom's or something contact her if you
have any questions about either of them
we play the power differences apparently
playing definitely on like Tekken no no
no I'm serious
well I know I won't be bored for the
next 18 hours but I'm surprised you're
very thankful trained killer
I have to admit at least they animate P
like lips and the eyes and stuff like
that they could have easily gotten away
with just like still still image oh I
see Final Fantasy 7 do you really though
rainbow then we go to final I want to
know how you get the code without the
box it's um the actual back of the
PlayStation classic I can google it nice
high star spry different you can also
google it at this point but I appreciate
that actually put out the terrible box
Oh Ben's in the chat yeah Ben's been
your Metal Gear
like if you're discovered by an enemy
you won't be able to use it yes it gets
jammed easily I'm afraid he actually
scored them no we don't really score
weight got it
I love dragon and I'm worried about
Bioware so I don't know it says there's
an announcement coming I would like
anthem to do well enough that firework
gets to make another dragon that's fair
we talking about this the other day yeah
at this point I don't know and drama was
the whole thing they should leave that
alone for a while but dragon like for
all my problems I had with Inquisition
it's still a good game and I like my
weapons are taken away
imagine yourself well if you make it
back in one piece maybe I'll let you do
a striptease smokes how did you do that
in my stomach thanks to the shot you
gave me to suppress my stomach asses how
are those going to help you better to
play this version of Twin Snakes I
prefer the original version over Twin
Snakes personally between snakes is a
totally fine version of me what are the
cigarettes do again they kind of calm
you down and calm you down and run door
but they'll never your health it's the
fastest way that's sneaking too much
risk of being spotted by the enemy
I can't just knock on the door and ask
them to let me in there's one sentry on
the left and one on the right they're
armed with five five sixes and
pineapples
yeah look like a famas
what about the air duct near the door
and I cheese Sniper Wolf or maybe you're
supposed to kill her the way I did I
needed her yeah I was like you know what
you're getting Nikita there's no way
around this we played twin snakes in the
office that's how we be here I'll let
you decide the best Co way I'm counting
on you snake oh you can count on me is
this person the pal version uh I don't
think this one is this is not as you see
this one's normal how big is the
controller this big oops
it's kind of out of focus but you get a
also this version you have to press
circle to confirm forgot all right we
got to save filling up this memory card
snake remember what the gold said the
graveyards are full of indispensable man
snake you're all alone I'm surrounded by
bad guys try to be careful and avoid
getting into a fight whenever you can
you're right both my parents are from
China but I was born and raised in
America
I've always liked reading literature
from both sides kind of keeps me in
touch I'll share some more quotes with
you if you like I'm looking forward to
it
but to tell you the truth I'd like to
learn more about you
what a player this guy was got Naomi
he's got mei-ling got Merrill he's got
gray fox yeah but the one true ship had
ship it and that was gonna make I like
it I like I like that you're willing to
risk it there
Oh fancy a is better than Final Fantasy
seven fight me I'm not willing to fight
you I know people that like to eat my
true horror story with ff7 is um oh is
that I got to Sephiroth and my saves got
lost so don't know and what I had to do
was I had to take my friends cuz I was
like hell no I'm not starting over again
and but my friends save was so good
because he had freaking Omni slash and
knights of the round so it kind of made
suffer off a joke
whereas I didn't have either and was
struggling like crazy hell I even had
the Prima guide back then get back when
prima guys were thing oh yeah great time
for a call probably like
you can't go by them probably not yeah I
don't think you can get I feel like I
can't like I tried this as a kid and it
didn't work like yeah yeah he was like
what was that I'm gonna go back to
that's fine
that was a week Eric should have played
again no dude I was I did not have it in
me to start over man that was that would
have been a that would have been so many
hours and I didn't have it in me I
couldn't watch Aris die again okay every
time it rips a small part of me out it's
tough
Joshua towbar if you want to know if
it's worth buying or not you should
check out our Peter Brown's PlayStation
classic review that'll help you make an
informed decision or just check out a
bunch of different reviews yeah we don't
review games here me and John Luke so
nope can't help you there unfortunately
but Peter Brown did some some stuff he
was pretty pretty whatever about it yeah
as his lead says prepare for
disappointment
and it also is awaiting greatness master
Miller he gets such an old ceremony at
the time is like whatever but like the
retro retro actively this makes it real
sad Peter didn't score it so super cool
that is not true no this isn't ff7 don't
worry we'll get to it in a second we'll
probably uh probably stop right now I
mean all right sure
in the rathole albert wesker question
where yeah we said we saw some Wesker
fights a fraud I don't think got that
far
all right on to ff7 all right no no
Rainbow six right I promise we're
supposed to do Rainbow six give it a
good five minutes this is another one
that came out after the DualShock I
don't know how this is gonna play and
we'll see probably not well we'll find
out yeah
Red Storm
[Music]
the year is 1999 well tell me about it
the Cold War has been over for more than
a decade and for the first time in a
half-century the world is free from the
specter of nuclear apocalypse it should
be a time of peace and prosperity but
all over the globe the embers of old
animosities have been fanned into flame
by the winds of freedom terrorism in the
21st century is an international
industry money and expertise flow freely
through the global computer network
harder and harder for the security
forces of individual nations to combat
this threat we're gonna skip that ooh
let's pick the UK here yeah she did hard
you only got one choice know one thing
let's do it okay
so you still like siege this is probably
it's more like your traditional one
where you tactically move them around
yeah exactly
five yeah beretta five grenades no
analog in FPS seven ETF all right
loading as I I like that he's filling up
his ammo that's a real person handgun Oh
more espionage baby how's it feel
probably better than gold and I'll tell
you that maybe not maybe on particle
than I so Goldeneye it probably is a
better frame rate than Goldeneye I feel
like that's the thing that actually like
both Goldeneye and Perfect Dark have
that rough rough framerate so that's how
I crouch wish I knew any of the buttons
ooh that one helped you zoom
thought you want that on any way you
want that autorun on oh oh geez yeah
it's gonna be like a golden night
there's no more one r22 old boy yeah you
like this
yikes yikes yikes yikes so I'm actually
not sure yeah nailed a all that actually
that uh smoke trail now it's gonna say
the the font on the bullets looked
exactly like goldeneye are these two
smoking crack not enough of it I've
never played Goldeneye on the PC so I
are on the yes oh right there right
there yeah I don't know how we didn't
see that okay weapons weapons I think
down the stair thing the Attic stairwell
over back where you were a little thing
that looks like a rug what is in a rug
okay I can't move forward though oh
really oh yeah how do I crouch
there we go
oh also I'm stuck okay okay
looking around plant we're doing this
tactically kind of wait so can you not
go down there I think I can I just like
getting stuck yeah
get rekt alright next downstairs
we didn't want to go from upstairs we
want to go from downstairs okay even
opened a freaking door you're asking the
wrong person
this is so bad alright new game oh
that's a hop bunny hop yeah is there
even like a G hopefully a man no it's
shot him this is like side this is like
to shoot this is like to jump so I'm out
of buttons I don't know how to open door
next game its own its own nose I would
love to I would love to know after ff7
you had to place to get into - your head
at the door yeah only that works
oh maybe gotta climb that ladder yeah a
fire escape
alright alright it's just there for show
oh wait okay I was right about that that
glass that the attic thing I just don't
know why you can fit through it yeah
also are you stuck
yep oh there we go nailed it oh your
teammate oh that's my teammate I would
hope so I mean [ __ ] I was gonna share
unawares if that is not your teammate
how is there you have no bullets now
sick real tactical nailed it options
alright new game and who came ff7 now
[Music]
yeah cloud baby veer ship drop being
abort mission
quick get us out of here
yeah I'm just gonna go ahead and say
that one does not hold up no I don't
know it's fine
yeah we're fine it's pretty good
that's pretty good John Lee this is
pretty good what are the viewers hot
hello welcome today to our PlayStation
classic stream we've gone through over
five games at least yep some of the
bigger ones the one with notable ones
thank you guys for tuning in
we're live pundit Friday 11:00 a.m. come
check us out
John Luke's usually on Friday with Ben
yep I'm really I'm usually here Monday
to Thursday yeah we'll do something
tomorrow I'm not sure what
always fly by the seat of our pants
unless we know we got some stuff there's
a lot of stuff next week I think next
week will be a bit it's true did you not
skip this one oh I can I was about to
say is the logo upscaled
logo of our these games on the system
yes the ones we're playing and then we
can go through the list if you want to
see it oh you're giving away V bucks
yeah give those B bucks away somewhere
else
see that's another interesting thing
Joseph s wants a dream Dreamcast classic
which he had brought up earlier but he
wants both Shenmue games and it should
have online support but we're still
waiting for a shed we put what like
Phantasy Star Online on it give me give
me the keyboard attachment and typing of
the Dead Toby that's pretty good I think
the dad's really enjoyed that game I
like that your mom I feel like Dreamcast
you'd have to put like a lot of fighting
games right like that's where you get
your they met the PlayStation live at
the start is that upscale oh no that's
um no like the that that is it's just
running off the original hardware
[Music]
and I'm still waiting for that remake
man I'm so hyped it's like what two
three years ago yeah babe I don't know
what's up with that
[Music]
it'll Midgar
[Music]
arrow you can stop spamming that I get
it
we were part of the rebellion second boy
that cartwheel
parkour
good show you what's up stuff I always
notices
that's a pitchman how today how do they
run by Baron like it's nothing and we're
stuck here we got into fight yeah but we
got the buster
[Music]
all right get them yeah
original thoughts
there's a remaster coming the fees who
knows we do have an original Xbox good
do not like that you can play a bunch of
I just want a song yeah there's a bunch
that gyri math or a massive but they got
backwards compatibility backwards
compatibility and support for 4k what
makes it look real nice actually
how old is GameSpot now jeez 22 is our
20th anniversary a my first my first
year here it's been 23 cents so we're 22
that seems good to me I can't
[Music]
yep you nailed it 22 years are you
playing Final Fantasy 7 yeah what are we
gonna name cloud cloud cloud okay didn't
even give the chat a chance to throw out
a random name nope
are there going to be any more dirty
arty videos I'm loving those that PM hop
yes there will be another one Friday I
believe
yes classic releases what the third
[Music]
50 white next week
yes
we should be next Tuesday I believe old
school
can it be hacked no idea
towards lightning from ff13 good
question I asked that for many years
when I had my ps3 I think they made all
the Final Fantasy 13 game what's that
big boss how you doing
glad you're able to make as well
[Music]
dan was seven all right man you're gonna
be screams bucket
[Music]
can't avoid it it's gonna happen
[Music]
[Music]
Marilyn seven subscribers oh yeah there
is an option to like speed it up though
but still man messing around
that's it forever freakin watching
frickin Sephiroth cast meteor that took
days
oh he haven't but now
I mean there's got to be a game on here
that if you had a Playstation you got
have got to be able to go back to enjoy
no that's that's a game I played in like
this was a one of my favorites on the on
the console for sure
definitely got my money's worth I had
both guides the Prima guide and whatever
the other one the Brady talk like
Grady's guides or something yeah
everything ratings guys Bradley Bradley
is it Bradley Brady guys okay Brady
guides is it pretty good yeah
yeah our Brady games same thing sure
Freeman is shutting down them yeah it's
crazy
just cuz everything can be digital now
like nobody uses I'd rather have the
hard copy of a guide in front of me I
also think most games don't need it
though like this there's very few games
that I feel like I wouldn't eat it
and ginger Greeks not a fan of the
turn-based fighting I don't mind it
maybe I'm just used to it though yeah
crisp absolutes no Xenogears no bye
that's another big one that I would like
to see
[Music]
I know Mega Man games
who knows how long did it take for that
roommate to come out
[Music]
yeah some people in this big boxing
legacy Akane
which that legacy
there's a lot that people could be good
one
who wants to play grand theft auto it's
on him
you threw something else we got one like
15 minutes problem yeah
call miss sure you can pick a different
one
all right let's pick a different one
didn't you want to play ocean to ocean
dunno a Wild Arms zone there just no
Wild Arms - hey you want your arms fixed
well I have my doubts or not doubts
necessarily but I am concerned about ffs
remake only because of like what's
happened like more recently with ff15
and my good DLCs and that just like a
huge fall out there actually paid too
much attention that's just because like
they were on that one engine and then
they didn't really use that engine right
for something like that it's like they
had a game engine they didn't they ended
up not using it or something like that I
got a I should have more details before
speaking but basically I know that you
know in light of the ff15 news it makes
me worry about FF remake and other like
I didn't yeah I'm actually not I heard
that there was something up with 15 what
what was good thing I have a computer
and fortunes dang it cuz I never beat up
at 15 but I like sort of like running
around like Road nature cancelled the
DLC left yeah so how do you a tabata
leaves that was after the like quarterly
I think you know earnings where they
lost again 33 million
oh you want some huh oh yeah you're
gonna get me here because I don't think
I played this I mean AG and kyon
so Ryu Ken Ryu Ken like I do here
I'm gonna go fo I think phone is a
little claw I'll wait oh dude good
dreamcast I could put the original sir
caliber on it mmm
Dreamcast classic it's for ya give all
my ideas the fighting games oh this
looks ok the Marvel vs. Capcom the
Darkstalkers high jump so high actually
Darkstalkers was a Saturn yeah Wow oh
you got a whip this definitely feels
more responsive than Oh what is this
what is going on
Oh doh jump off don't ring out i baited
you Oh
twirly Clarke
we do every good question oh yeah I know
what's up that was quarter circle for it
or something
okay cross you up oh right over her head
just the sidestepping is so slow I do it
squirrel when I do the sidestep to
Thunder ring cuz this game said I know
how and one told me how to do it I would
also oh what just happened I think oh
did you kick it I think I kicked the F I
pushed it was so far away
oh please surround look at that Oh
sidestep dish
Oh
[Music]
got my reasons so poor oh yeah don't
know how I did it scratch them half
circle back in square okay Chinese yeah
he's got two closets that pictures
mustache time to go it bel-air
I don't want crime to think I only play
male fighters we're playing is it Toshi
didn't yes battle arena battle ocean
didn't fireball oh I got twin blades
oh but smash right that's a very
interesting outfit she has your superior
reach oh oh so slow slide I'm basically
Ibuki Oh dodged it I'm some type of
weird okay hurt her sidestep
it's very slow oh no I I expose myself
ooh Oh what is that whoa Jonathan
there's no superior each half circle
forward half circle back punch
wow that's Haney plug I need some help
oh why did that do like no damage
[Music]
oh my god to read
please lie
that move looks like it should do way
more and it does like nothing oh my knee
oh jeez Oh had to use her capoeira try
this combo Eric just win don't wear
Thanks Ellis's do dragon punch square
alright you got it
wake up EP I'm a Ken fighter reach
Oh No wake up VP doesn't work
oh the damage sure this movies ooh it is
why does that do nothing much you might
get a jail card
who do you treat all right that's the
three one one
let's run go got is that like a like a
big-ass mace all right I'll try the guy
with the tank top
yeah it's like a hammer oh oh I'm a club
you dude I am yoked
I have big bare arm well I'll see you
later yeah I'm just leaving now oh I got
a fireball dude projectiles
Oh what am i doing oh hey mondo do
dragon punches that's for you all right
echoes prehistoric yeah man I'm a
caveman wrong go do fireball square yeah
I did that oh the mo he reminds me to
kill like your guy oh yeah oh geez
bashed
got mixing the kick alright see other
rhythm I guess - oh dude look at how big
my pecs are
gather up
oh no I need my crazy get out of free
jail card oh man this game was awesome
at the time I could see why but dude
look at my pics
I have no waste I just have it like
upper torso I I don't even know you want
to call a stream go back to the was a
good one that was good that was good
nice even pretty even Stephens match
yeah play some classic we only checked
out a couple the games I feel like we
got through a third of them the big ones
like what the hell is jumping fish like
jumping flash flash it's apparently this
like first-person like puzzle Ridge like
platformer okay that that was like came
out before Mario so what kind of that's
sort of it's like claim to fame but I
can't play a little bit of it and I was
like yeah this thing's weird I don't
know I don't and I'm not particularly
interested in picking one up I just
don't think the games are there for me
and then that's the stuff they've done
on the emulation side nice though but is
$100 nice hard to say I mean like I
definitely got something a stout of that
sure I don't know like I like the
controllers the controllers do get to it
you do get to it okay and and the system
itself looks pretty nice yeah it's a
nice little box but puzzle fighter
there's a also fighters Jam mmm that's
true cool well thank you so much for
coming on two streams I'll see you
tomorrow obviously and come back
tomorrow at 11 a.m. if you guys didn't
know
we'll be back Monday to Friday 11 a.m.
guess what live hit that sub button if
you have it
alright see you later already ship you
tomorrow - bye